[Music]
many people think that Maslow's
hierarchy of needs stopped with
self-actualization and that's not
actually true he had another piece that
was on top of self-actualization and
that was self transcendence he just
didn't publish it widely before he
passed away it was something he started
working on towards the end and so he
published the hierarchy of needs before
he finished his work on self
transcendence he was one of the first
people really to track flow and to track
some of the more interesting and
advanced altered states that human
beings can get to things that you would
find the terminology really similar to
things that you've heard that heard
advanced meditators described and so he
was working on self transcendence and he
just did it publish it so there's
actually another level on top of that
hierarchy of needs and so when I think
of human psychology
I really think of human psychology as a
spectrum and it's not a it's not a
series of of islands or unique locations
it's really sort of a spectrum and on
one end you have what I call areas that
require human support so these are this
is when people are facing you know
severe stress severe anxiety and
depression and then in the middle is
what I call the human condition and so
that is loneliness happiness connection
empathy the human condition is where we
learn how to deal with our first
heartbreak and the first time that we
fall in love the human condition is
where we deal with sadness and betrayal
and loss basically all the things that
happen to you as you grow up through
life the full spectrum of human emotion
that is the human condition and there's
a you know there's a
infinite number of songs on the radio
and poems and art that's about the human
condition so that's there and then on
this other side which I think really
maps to self transcendence and Maslow's
later work is the part of the people in
the world who are really pushing on
human psychology and what are the limits
where are our boundaries what is the
frontier of human psychology and I think
a lot of direction that we get is from
the contemplative communities around the
world who really have been exploring and
pushing on human psychology for as long
as humans have been organized and and in
pushing on what it is what does it mean
to be human the other day I talked to a
guy who now has three Guinness World
Book Records on endurance sports and he
meditates the entire time and he just he
just swam the English Channel in a
speedo and he meditated the whole time
so you know people are using mind
training meditation and other things to
push into abilities that right now today
you one could say are limited to the few
but with the advent of things like
transformative technology there is the
ability the possibility the potentiality
of these extraordinary States abilities
and conditions to be available to a much
wider group of people and the reason why
I think it's relevant is you know what
would make it significant relevant and
actionable is that is that when I think
about the world today and the challenges
facing mankind I don't think the
problems are technical I think they're
human so last summer I went to
singularity University I took time out
of everything that I'm doing to go into
their Graduate Studies
it was a fantastic program I love
singularity University and the way that
the program is set up is that it's this
10-week program and you're in class from
9:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m. every night and
there's just a parade really of some of
the most extraordinary people on the
planet working either in exponential
technology so AI robotics 3d printing
bioinformatics be everything you could
imagine and people who are on the front
lines of the challenges facing mankind
like the people who are working on the
water problems the people who are
teaching in the refugee camps the people
who are trying and working legitimately
sleeves rolled up on the ground the
thinking around su is it's the place
where exponential technologies are
applied to the grand global challenges
that are facing mankind and that being
the purpose and the use for them so for
me while I was there my questions always
centered on what is your biggest
challenge to what you're trying to
accomplish and the answers were not
technical the answers were human it was
about fear one zone or the people around
you they were all human problems and it
was interesting to spend the entire
summer there because you definitely walk
away with the feeling that the the
problems are technical we always figure
it out we got a man on the moon and we
have alternative energy and there's so
many other things that are happening so
fast change is coming hard and fast just
you know from year to year if you see
the difference in the quality of the
robots and the robotic competitions it's
dramatic year after year after year and
so really the challenge facing mankind
is human it's can we get past the fear
aggression anxiety stress can we get
past that inner dialogue that takes us
off track either makes us miss out on
game day not perform makes us unable to
create
collaborations and cooperate with other
people because we do have very real
challenges as a species and the only way
that we're going to solve them is
together we have some very serious
conversations that we have to have about
everything from genetic engineering to
you know what do we do with a lot of the
technologies that are coming online
whether you know whether it's
algorithmic accountability your variety
of things and so the way that I see my
work and the way that I see
transformative technology is that if we
can use the technology to understand
ourselves better if we can use the
technology to start to deliver and help
people mimic the experiences of
meditation so that people can be calmer
happier understand themselves better
silence the critical voices in the
inside themselves that stir up a lot of
trouble and if they can also connect to
other people better then we can get busy
doing the work that needs to be done to
create the future that we'd like to have
for ourselves and for our children and
our communities on the planet so that's
that's why I'm doing what I'm doing
[Music]